how you doing Seth I'm very well how are
you I'm doing fine now is this you are
getting married soon I'm getting married
uh next month and uh
uh I'm very excited about it uh yeah
everything's going uh according to plan
are you gonna have a uh I don't you know
you know you're gonna have the ceremony
itself but you're gonna have a crazy
stag party uh
craziness I'm not gonna do that uh
because I'm uh horrified as to what
might happen at it to be honest uh my
friend's party much harder than I can as
it is uh and I recover much slower than
I used to a hangover for me now lasts
around seven weeks
so I I don't have quite the yeah I can't
do it like I used to so if you told your
friends we're just gonna go someplace
quiet have some soup and then go to
sleep yeah we're gonna have some soup
and some crackers maybe a baked apple
nice nice
warm apple I know I would I know I'd
have one of those matching parties where
someone dies and then we have to bury
them and then one of my friends is gonna
tell on us so that we have to kill him
too and bury him and next thing you know
I've killed all my friends and uh how
did you end up killing all your friends
well then the other one would rat on us
for killing the other one obviously yeah
I've thought about this like yeah a lot
of thought you're digging a lot of holes
in the desert yeah but there's a lot of
desert to big holes in my friends so
[Laughter]
let's just not have that status right so
I'd rather just not do it now I'm
imagining uh you've got a female falling
some disappointed ladies out there that
you're going to tie the knot uh some not
nearly as many as disappointed dudes as
it seems like there might be uh
uh well as you know I'm a bear icon
um now let's clarify for people who
don't know because it's been discussed
on our show before
bears are big hairy dudes that gay guys
like okay
my friend
um because I'm big and hairy and gay
guys seem to like that's a
classification of gay dude big hairy uh
bear man and uh and uh it was recently
brought to my attention that I am I am
such a bear icon my friend will actually
who wrote 50 50 sent this to me he he
told me that I'm I'm a muse in the uh
creative community of the bear loving
world and um like the Venus de Milo
maybe perhaps or the uh so
um so so people in the bear Community
who are artists use you as their
inspiration and one guy used me as the
centerpiece for a book that he made
um and it's all about what a wonderful
bear icon I am okay yeah I don't know
what we can show and what we can't we
should just show it I think we should
show this okay let's start with the
first one this is real this is real this
is real
Trio
so what he's doing that's supposed to be
using is that you just like me look it
kind of I think that looks pretty good
honestly it looks more like Curly from
The Three Stooges
it's not quite it's an Observe and
Report me it's like a little heavier but
yeah I see I see I call that one Lazy
Sunday that one's just
is that at all how you really lie down
that is exactly how I lie down when I'm
naked and my penis actually looks like
that with little cubes all over it uh
there's a treatment there's a cream
there's more though oh there's more
what's the next one in title
no it's not good
are you in a are you in a snowbank
it's just a really fluffy comforter it's
just a really good what do you what do
you call this one that's called come and
get me that call that one remember
now you should tell us the title of the
last one before we see it tell us the
title before we see it I call this last
one peekaboo okay let's see peek-a-boo
no
[Applause]
incredible
someone's got their Christmas card
the guy really be too that's what's
crazy what do you mean he got you that's
what my body looks like like he really
like he kept it
it's funny because I'm flacciding all of
them I think
but now be honest have you tried that
post since just to get like I actually
have just to see if it it's 85 accurate
yeah I can't quite get my head that much
under my testicles
[Laughter]
show will never be broadcast on PBS